hey guys it's max we just got in the
brand new ipad air
4 and today we are going to be comparing
it
against the 2020 ipad pro we're going to
look at everything the
performance of the new a14 and how much
faster
is it faster than the a12z we'll look at
the new touch id compared to face id
we'll compare the speakers
are they as good as these amazing ones
on the ipad pro
and does the apple pencil work just as
well without promotion
let's find out now i got to be honest
with you guys
i wasn't that excited for this ipad air
4.
it's really similar to the ipad pro but
so many of you guys keep asking for it
you can't wait to see videos on it
so i'm glad we have it in now i have the
green color
and that's one of the things you can't
get with the ipad pros the airs have a
lot of cool color options
right away two things stand out now the
most obvious one is the camera bump
but we're also missing this band at the
top
which even the 2018 ipad pro had
the new ipad air 4 has the same camera
module from the previous ipad pro
whereas with the 2020 we have this much
larger
iphone 11 and 12 style design we have an
additional
ultra wide camera and we have the
lidar sensor the last difference is that
the ipad pro
does have a flash which could be useful
for scanning
documents now apart from this they look
very
similar that's because recently the ipad
air just keeps following the ipad pro's
design
so if we take a look at it they look
similar we can put them up on their
sides
and they have this new flat edge design
that we have
with the new iphones it looks really
nice it looks more modern
and as you see when we stack them up
like this they look basically identical
the size
is the same now why would apple want to
make a potential
ipad pro killer with the same design
well
that is to sell more magic keyboards
and i have to say that i love this thing
other than the price and if you guys
want to see our full detailed review
on this magic keyboard search up max
tech magic keyboard and you'll find it
and also so it could support the new
apple pencil 2
which has more features it's nicer and
it's way more convenient to charge now
there's a couple more external
differences that i noticed
first off we do have two grilles on each
side
even though the new ipad air 4 doesn't
have quad speakers like the ipad pro
it does have dual stereo speakers and
these speaker grilles
the actual cutouts are slightly larger
now the other one
is that the ipad air 4 has just two
microphones it has one
where the camera is and one up top
whereas the pro
has two on top and then it has one
additional one
on the side over here now we're going to
be testing out the speakers
and the microphone quality in just a bit
and the last difference is that we now
have touch id
instead of face id so let's go ahead and
set it up it's right here
and it's pretty dang large it's very
interesting to
to feel it and i have to say that it
feels kind of awkward reaching up
and around the corner to reach the
sensor i feel like it would have been
better on the side over here like on
some samsung's but i guess it depends
if you use your ipad more vertically or
in landscape
i do have to add that i'm very used to
just tapping on the screen and swiping
up
on my ipad or my iphone and now
you do have to go ahead and put your
finger up there it's an extra step
and with that magic keyboard it is going
to be a little bit less convenient
and now let's compare the displays and i
didn't think that i would notice a
bigger bezel on the ipad air 4 because
it's a 10.9 inch display
compared to 11 that's almost identical
just a few pixels
but you guys can clearly see that the
bezel is thicker now if you're buying
just ipad air 4 you don't have a pro
you won't notice this the bezel is even
on all sides and it's a nice improvement
over the ipad air 3. now i can't tell
any difference in terms of
quality the detail is identical because
the pixels per inch
are very close but let's go ahead and
test out
the brightness because the ipad pro can
reach 600 nits compared to 500
now along with that i'm noticing that
the air 4 actually loses brightness
much more so if you're looking at an off
angle so at the top right now the
brightness is identical but from the
side it's a lot dimmer
and let's check out the reflectivity
we're going to shut these off
and very interesting
i was not expecting this so the new ipad
air 4 is actually
less reflective than the ipad pro
and instead of it looking slightly
bluish here on the ceiling tile it looks
more black and it's just the the
reflections aren't as
sharp so it looks like apple might have
newer better coatings
and now let's talk about pro motion this
is probably one of the biggest
differences
between these two tablets and it's
really hard to show off on video so we
actually set our a7s three above to 4k
120 frames per second so we're going to
show you guys some slow motion clips
and let's just go side to side here at
the home screen
i mean to me this is very noticeable we
wanted pro motion on the new iphone 12s
which we don't have but here the ipad
pro is insanely smooth
perfectly whereas as the air 4 it just
looks like the previous air or even the
budget ipad
now i don't think that that alone makes
the ipad pro worth it
but having 9 milliseconds of latency
with the apple pencil 2
could this is just incredible with in
real time i'm not noticing
any latency whatsoever there's no lag
everything's
perfect and here's a clip in slow motion
you guys maybe will notice a little bit
but it is perfect for regular use now
apple doesn't tell us what the latency
is with the ipad air 4.
so finally let's find out all right and
that is very quick too surprisingly
quick now i am noticing
one thing when i'm going quickly i don't
know if it's latency or if it's just the
graphics
almost like it has a dropped frame or
something but this is
miles better than when i tested some of
the older galaxy
tabs where those would lag behind quite
a bit let's try something a little
thinner and slower
and looking here from the side i could
tell that there is a little bit latency
it's just the refresh rate it's
refreshing at half the speed of the ipad
pro
now realistically for most people it's
still going to be
just fine and now let's go ahead and
compare the speakers
and i'm so curious how the ipad air 4
will keep up
go ahead and put on your best pair of
headphones and let's take a listen
[Music]
let me know your thoughts down in the
comment section below
but hearing it live i have to say that i
was hoping for
a little bit more we have four speaker
grills here the speaker cutouts are
larger
but the base isn't as deep the mids
aren't as full and the highs especially
the highs are not as crisp
and clean that is because we don't have
any sound coming from
these speaker grilles right here they're
just for looks i guess
uh compared to the ipad pro which we
have
the mids and the bass coming from the
bottom firing speakers
and then from the top ones that's where
we have the higher frequencies
and it ends up sounding great it's
louder as well
sounds better overall and it's also more
immersive you hear sound
just coming right through the screen
it's a very great experience for
watching movies now that doesn't mean
that the ipad air 4 is bad
it's a great upgrade over the previous
ipads that have just speakers just at
the bottom
but it doesn't sound as good when you're
listening to them side by side and one
other thing that really stands out
when i'm playing back a video or
listening to something
in the vertical or portrait mode i hear
majority of the sound from my left ear
and my right ear here is a lot less so
you definitely could tell
that the speakers are on this left-hand
side and now let's compare the
microphone quality along with the
front-facing camera
which is great for facetime this is
recording on the ipad pro and this is
the ipad air 4's
video and microphone quality go ahead
and let me know which one
looks better and which one sounds better
down in the comments section below
and now let's get into performance we're
going to use geekbench 5 here
and let's go ahead and start our cpu
test and we'll see
can the new 5 nanometer a14
keep up with the monster a12z
and we have our results and this is
interesting
as far as single core score the new a14
is over 40 faster from 11 22
to 1588 that is a big jump
but as far as multi-core score the ipad
pro is actually about 10
faster we also have a difference in ram
the ipad pro has 6 gigs of ram
compared to 4 gigs on the ipad air 4.
so if you're somebody does a lot of
multitasking maybe you're doing things
like video editing or something else
that's very difficult
the ipad pro might be a little bit
better but for more basic simple tasks
the ipad air 4 might actually be quicker
and now
let's compare the graphics using the
metal test
and this is where it's going to be
interesting because the ipad
pro is an absolute beast in terms of
graphics performance
all right and wow the new ipad air 4
actually beats out the ipad pro in terms
of
graphics we have 12 000 which is super
high
and 12 542 on the air
4. now this is crazy because the a14 in
here has a 4 core gpu
compared to an 8 core gpu
and this means that if you're somebody
that's gaming or doing things that use
metal you're not going to be missing out
on any performance
and the next ipad pro or the apple
silicon max are going to be
absolutely crazy based on this 5
nanometer technology
and now let's briefly talk about battery
life now of course we just got the ipad
air 4
but there's a couple things that we can
grab from what we know so far
now the batteries should be identical in
these two just like we had
in the 2018 ipad pro and
with that the ipad air 4 it has
two less speakers to power and the
display isn't as bright
either and on top of that we have the
new a14
that is more efficient it's using five
nanometer and as far as the graphics
cores we have four of them
and they they're very powerful but it's
four to power instead of eight
so if we had to guesstimate we would say
that real world battery life will be
a bit better on the ipad air 4. now
along with that i also want to point out
that the new ipad air 4 does come with a
20 watt usb type-c charger
instead of 18 watts so you should be
able to charge up just a little bit
faster as well
and now let's go ahead and talk about
the cameras and we have a lot of
similarities and differences
now the front-facing camera is 7
megapixels on
both of them they look like they're the
same ones but because of the face
id we actually have the ability to shoot
portrait shots which you can't on the
ipad air for
now the main sensor on the back they're
both 12 megapixels so there's really no
differences there
but the ipad pro does have an ultra wide
camera which is 10 megapixels now
personally
i don't really know what would be a good
use for this let us know what you would
use it for down in the comment section
below
and also let us know which of these
photos look better the pro also has a
flash
which could be nice for scanning
documents in bad
lighting here you guys can see the
difference and the last difference
is that along with the extra camera we
have the lidar sensor
or scanner and that will help out with a
r for measuring just for making
everything a lot more accurate
and along with that you could do things
like scanning
objects into 3d models and before we get
into the final verdict of which one of
these you should buy
let's talk about prices and storage the
ipad pro comes with 128 gigs
of storage compared to 64 on the ipad
air
4. now if you need more than 64 gigs
you actually have to spend 150 bucks
and get 256 so there's no 128 gig
option and that brings it up much more
in price
to the 800 ipad pro so instead of 600
for the base
you're at 750. if you're somebody that
wants to watch movies
maybe surf the web do some email maybe
play a little bit of games 64 gig
might be enough but if you want to do
things like edit photos and videos
and use it as a laptop replacement 64
gigs really isn't enough
and for our verdict which one of these
should you buy
and i have to say the answer has never
been more clear to me
when i'm doing these kinds of
comparisons if you're looking to buy
the ipad air 4 and you're going to buy
the base model
and you're going to use it just by
itself without the keyboard or the apple
pencil
you're not going to upgrade the storage
i would absolutely get the ipad air 4.
it's going to be a great device and a
great upgrade
over previous ipads but with that said
if you're considering upping the storage
or if anytime in the future you know
you're going to buy an apple pencil
and possibly the magic keyboard there is
no reason for you to spend the money
on the ipad air 4 and save that little
bit because the price difference once
you add in
the extras once you add in the storage
it's very small
and you get so much extras with the ipad
pro you get the better display with
better brightness
better viewing angles along with that
the speakers are quite a bit better
you have the extra storage and you have
pro motion which is
excellent just all around and especially
if you want to use the apple pencil
along with that if you're watching this
in the future go ahead and check the
links in the video description we'll
have links to both of these
because the ipad pro could be on sale
we've seen it on sale before
whereas the ipad air 4 is a new device
it's going to stick to that 600
price of course i want to hear your
guys's opinions down in the comment
section below
and we are going to be using the ipad
air 4 for a bit we're gonna have a
gaming comparison
we're gonna do a one week later real
world comparison between these two
what are the other small things that i
noticed as i'm using the ipad air for
so make sure you guys click that circle
above to subscribe and if you want to
see
a couple great videos we have some right
over there thank you guys for watching
this been max and i'll see you in the
next video